aux alentours de 17h30 vendredi 27 mars
le bilan de la journée tombe près de
1000 personnes sont décédées de jeudi à
vendredi
969,4 précis au total l'italie déplorent
9134 morts depuis le début de la
pandémie au nombre de cas recensés
les transalpins compte plus de 80 6000
personnes infectées selon le dernier
bilan des autorités locales
un chiffre sous-estimé selon le
directeur de l'hôpital cazals pas locaux
de rome le nombre de sujets infectés
sûrement plus élevé que ce qu'il ressort
officiellement du bulletin du soir
déclaré car il y à des patients qui se
sont mis en quarantaine sans avoir été
testé ils sont chez eux ils guérissent
lentement il y à des sujets qui ont
probablement attrapé le virus
à coup sûr ils ne l'ont pas remarqué ils
ont surmonté donc le nombre de personnes
infectées est absolument plus élevé que
ce qui a été dit pour lutter contre la
propagation du coffee 19 des drones de
surveillance vont être déployées comme
ici dans la ville de messine où ils
contrôleront la distanciation sociale
dans les rues et mettront la voix du
maire ordonnant aux gens de rester chez
eux
autre initiative pour soulager les
hôpitaux saturés des médecins
appartenant à une unité spéciale de
lagence de protection de la santé
italienne se rendent chez des malades
pour effectuer des consultations à
domicile
notre activité consiste à prendre en
considération tous les patients qui ne
peuvent pas consulter leur médecin
nous traitons les cas liés aux kovy 19
d'abord par téléphone puis nous
effectuerons une visite à domicile
à l'international la chine cuba ou
encore la russie où on faire leur aide à
l'italie ce vendredi des médecins
militaires russes ont désinfecté une
maison de retraite à bergame vingt
personnes sont mortes ici au cours des
trois dernières semaines le virus a
circulé et nous sommes ici pour aider à
le combattre
nous procédons maintenant aux mesures de
désinfection
toutes les zones sont désinfectés à
l'éthanol images fortes
le pape françois s'est rendu à la
basilique saint pierre dont le parvis
était désert confinement oblige il y a
énoncé une prière mondiale contre la
pandémie
l'italie peut tout de même s'appuyer sur
une lueur d'espoir
plus de 10000 italiens sont désormais
considérés comme guéris